[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and since our previous
Dragon Ball super video about who will
be the final villain in the series
generated a lot of great discussion in
the comments and with the newest Goku
transformation about to be introduced I
thought it would be fun to make a quick
video theorizing about what Goku's final
form might look like personally I
believe that Dragon Ball super is still
going to continue for quite a while due
to its immense popularity and I also
believe that the new Goku form that has
been teased in the previews will not be
his final form so in this video I will
use our knowledge of the wider Dragon
Ball franchise along with Japanese
culture and symbolism in order to
speculate what Goku's final form might
look like since this is a theory video I
invite you guys to give me your own
theories down in the comments I love
hearing your thoughts and getting a good
conversation going do you think that the
new Goku form that has been teased will
be his final form or do you think there
are more forms still to come let me know
down below now we know that the hair
color of sands changes as they reach new
forms so we have regular super sense
having blond hair the Super Saiyan God
form has red hair super Sam blue has
blue hair of course and so on and so the
question is what will go whose final
form the most powerful sand
transformation possible look like what
color hair will this Saiyan form have
and will there be actual meaning behind
this color or will it just be random
back in the 1990s after Dragon Ball GT
finished airing a drawing of a Super
Saiyan 5 form fooled a lot of Dragon
Ball fans they thought that this drawing
was a leak from Japan and that this
Super Sentai form would be introduced in
the near future but it turned out to be
that this was a fan made image that
originated in Spain not Japan however
one thing I really liked about this fan
made form was that it was drawn with
greyish white hair because white hair
has a lot of meaning in Japanese culture
and
anime as a medium in particular anime
characters with white hair often have
mystical magical or godly powers think
of Inuyasha
Tachibana Kannada from Angel Beats and
UA from Cardcaptor Sakura white hair
also symbolizes wisdom self-control
discipline purity Awakening and new
beginnings in addition we know that Goku
Super Saiyan God form has red hair which
is reminiscent of flames and Super
Saiyan blue which is the Super Saiyan
transformation combined with the Super
Saiyan God form has blue hair an
interesting scientific fact is that blue
flames are known to be hotter than red
flames so it makes sense for Super
Saiyan blue to be a higher form in this
case moreover the absolutely hottest
flames possible are known to burn a blue
white color the flame is blue around the
outer edges and white at the core
closest to the source of the flame to
continue this flame analogy I believe
that in his final form
Goku hair will move beyond blue and
become white the other characters that
have white hair and draggable super are
of course the angels the most powerful
creatures other than Zeno himself and
sama soo and fused the muscles it's
interesting to note that the masu also
has silver eyes and in his new form goku
will also have silver eyes so it would
make sense to me if the form that goku
eventually reaches beyond this one will
be one where his hair becomes white in
anime characters with white hair are
often shown as self-sufficient and as
loners as if they're above the concerns
of normal mortals think of near from
bethe node and ginkgo from Liu shishi
and this leads me to another point
discussed in our who will be the final
villain in Dragon Ball super video one
of the theories examined in that video
is that Goku could potentially become
the final villain in Dragon Ball super
but the only way that I could see
something like that happening is if in
his Final Four Goku becomes so powerful
that he can no longer relate to ordinary
humans if Goku reaches a form that
rivals the angels and maybe even
approaches the power of Z know he could
theoretically control entire universes
and if this were the case then the petty
affairs of individual mortals would mean
nothing to him just like the destruction
of entire planets and the erasing of
entire universes means nothing to Zen
know if something like this happened
then I could see Goku becoming the final
villain for Dragon Ball super
if he loses touch with reality and
becomes this sort of otherworldly
godlike figure that doesn't care about
mortals Gohan and the others would have
to try to bring him back to his senses
before it's too late to go along with
that let's not forget the characters
with white hair turning out to have dark
hearts and becoming villains is a common
trope in anime just look at vicious from
Cowboy Bebop makishima Shogo from
Psychopaths Griffith from berserk and of
course as mentioned earlier za masu and
potentially the angels in Dragon Ball
super itself and on top of that in
fiction silver eyes often symbolize a
cold unwavering and unapproachable
person that has little time for other
people and is concerned only with their
own ultimate goal this was certainly
true for za masu in Dragon Ball super so
could it also be true for Goku in his
final form is draggable super
foreshadowing that with enough power
Goku might become like Sam ah su and the
angels and he could start thinking of
mortals as lesser beings let me know
what you think will go who's final form
have white hair and will this form be so
powerful that it will make Goku lose
touch with the worries of mortals and
turn into some sort of villain also what
would this final form with white hair be
called Super Saiyan white Super Saiyan
immortal Omni Goku let me know down in
the comments what your thoughts are if
you want to check out our previous
Dragon Ball super videos you can check
out our who will be the final villain in
Dragon Ball super video and our every
Frieza transformation explained video
links in the description and if you
in the description you will also see the
links to all of the deviant-art pages
that I could find for the fan art that I
used in this video I think it's very
important to give credit to artists
whenever we can so if you want to check
those out links in the description and
that is it for this video guys if you
want to see more draggable super content
on this channel be sure to hit that like
button if you are new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and click that
notification bell and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]